foreign
if you ever wondered how to Leverage The
Power of charge DPT the AI language
model to creating compelling creating
app for your channel you are in the
right place in this video I will guide
you through the process of how to make
an app with the help of chargpt
capabilities and some of other AI tools
so let's dive in and unlock the
potential of AI assistant but before we
begin let me tell you guys that we have
regular updates on multiple Technologies
videos so if you are a tech geek on a
continuation for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to a YouTube channel
and press that Bell icon to never miss
any update from Simply learn also
accelerate your career in AIML with
Comprehensive postgraduate program in Ai
and ml gain expertise machine learning
deep learning NLP computer vision and
reinforcement learning you will receive
a prestigious certificate exclusive
alumni membership and hackathons and AMA
sessions by IBM
with three Capstone and 25 plus industry
project using real data sets from
Twitter Uber and more you will gain
practical experience master classes
papadi faculty and IBM expert ensure
top-notch education simply run job
assist help you to get noticed by
Leading companies live session on AI
trends like chat Deputy generative Ai
and explainable AI this program covers
statistics python supervised and
unsupervised learning NLP
neural network computer vision gns Keras
tensorflow and many more skills so why
wait and Rule now and unlock exciting Ai
and ml opportunity the course link is in
the description box below dive in and
see how chatbt can help you to make a
great app so here we have share GPT okay
you can write here chat dot openair.com
so here I will ask to charge gbt what is
chargeability so I will write what is
chat
so here you can stop generating if you
want to okay I will stop generating okay
so charge bit is a conversational
artificial intelligence model developed
by open air it is based on the GPT
generative pre-trained transform
architecture specifically GPT 3.5 which
is at Advanced language model so GPT 3.5
is trained on a massive amount of tax
data to generate human like response to
wide range of prompts and question
you can ask anything to charge GPT
okay
after coming
chat
GPT
software
Developers
save
software developer jobs
see
yes after the introduction of charge gbt
and similar language model software
developer still have important roles and
their jobs remain regular while AI
models like chargpt can generate text
and provide automated response they have
limitations see they have limitations
charitivity have limitation and cannot
replace the skills and expertise of
human software Developers
so here is a few reasons why software
developer jobs remain valuable okay so
here are the few reasons so you can ask
anything to charge gbt
so what we will do we will create a
small small gaming app okay so here I
will write
uh
let's make first tic-tac-toe okay so
here I will write
give
me the code
for tick
tag to
game
see it will give you the step by step
charge gbt will explain you everything
see this board
then player check columns check
diagonals play game everything switch
check for the winner play game
I believe see to play the game simply
run the python script players will take
turns entering the row column numbers to
make their moves the game will
okay so what I will do okay first I will
ask the steps to make a game tic-tac-toe
okay
give me these steps
to me
see positively we will ask for these
steps then we will ask for the code
chargity can make your app in 2-3
minutes in just 2-3 minutes small small
app and two three minutes
okay see what what is the first step set
up the game board create a data
structure to represent the tic-tac-toe
board this can be three by three Grid or
nested list with initial empty values
okay for example this then second is the
print the game board write a function to
display the current state of the board
on the screen this will help players
visualize their game
and the third is get player input prompt
the player to enter their moves except
the input for the rows and columns where
the players want to place their symbol X
or zero okay
or you can change the value X or 0
whatever cross right okay
update the board after receiving the
player input update the game board with
their move make sure to validate the
move and check if the selected position
is empty
okay then check for the winner then
check for it is draw word then alternate
turns
okay then repeat two to seven until the
game ends optional additional features
we will first we will make tic-tac-toe
uh what you can say a simple tic-tac-toe
then we will add the additional features
on this okay using charge GPT only Okay
so
I will write
provide me the
tick
tag
to
a code
what we will do we will open the visual
studio and copy it directly
obviously current player is X
then o
see currently row the second player
switch player
okay what we will do we will copy it
from here and we will open the visual
studio that new file I will write here
take the
2 dot P1 okay Enter
I will save it so here I will directly
copy the code
where's my
it comes in
okay
copied this also
copied the whole thing
okay I have to remove this or I can make
it you know comment
yeah
so let's try to run it
what terminal says
see enter the row
okay
two
enter the column
okay it made like this
okay
what I will do
I will ask for the geoi
provide me the
click
attack so okay with GUI
y okay now the Tinker came Tinker is
python Library used for the GUI in
Python
okay okay now uh
we'll copy the code and just paste it it
will run okay with GUI and then we will
add the additional features okay from
here now I'm copying the code
now select all replace with this code
like here no error no red sign so let me
play it
it will run I guess no problems
okay what happened see as you can see
we got the tic tac toe
okay so see here x 0 x
0 x player expense
so let me add the additional features in
this
so what we will do is
go to chat GPT again we'll ask for the
additional feature see
load the code above uses the message box
module from the Tinker for displaying
messages ensure that you have compatible
version to think okay when you run this
quota graphical windows will appear by
three by three give and this okay
players can click on the buttons to make
their move the game state will okay
um
okay
update you can you know talk to charity
so I will say update
my code with some
good
phone and scoreboard
scoreboard
front scoreboard and color
update my GUI code I can write
here is an update see like certainly
here is an updated version of GUI code
with improved font scoreboard and color
if you get error in this you can ask to
chat GPT okay
anything you are facing issue about your
code whatever it is you can ask directly
to chat GPT
see we created an App in like two
minutes just in two minutes
so charitivity is making our life easier
okay let me copy this code
okay
let's see the changes
what WhatsApp charge but it does
okay
nothing changed I guess
player expense like this cross
okay
I will write here
see in this updated code the font style
has been improved with a bold aerial
font the buttons have a custom
background color and the overall window
and discover have a different color
oh I didn't feel like this
I didn't feel like this
okay so
change
change the
grid Style
of the
game
Thanksgiving updating the boat
seem to change the gradient side of the
same you can modify variance of the
buttons and the spacing between them is
an updated version jio I code with the
modified register
it's just a little bit of time taking
that's it nothing else it's very useful
chargity you can create your app in 2-3
minutes
okay
continue generating it's a half code
okay code is copied
let me select and paste it here
check see
player x0 player row zero
okay it's little bit different I guess
okay this one two three box why these
lines there
okay who cares
play the expense okay see the scoreboard
is updated
okay
so this is how you can make your Tic Tac
Toe more beautiful
okay uh let me write here
let me write here I want the black and
white boxes okay or colorful boxes
so
um
code
provide me the code for a colorful
okay
okay here
foreign certainly here is an updated
version of the code with colorful boxes
instead of grid lines
okay
so we're waiting for the code update the
code
see in this updated code each player's
button xno has a specific color assigned
to it the button colors okay let me
copy the code and paste it here
and run it
see the color is changed
and I will write c x
o x o x o x
player expense
okay so this is how you can make your
app more beautiful beautiful using
customization you can ask share GPT
anything color style font or any
function
anything you can ask and you you can
make your app
more beautiful okay
so now let's move on to the next game
which I want a snake game okay using pi
game we will make
so here I will write please provide
me the code
of snake
game
using
Fire game python
okay
everyone knows what is this next game
or first you want to ask the steps we
can ask the steps okay after this I will
ask this step
okay
so till then let's make a new file of
snake
game Dot py
okay
let me close it
see it's a long
code like us just continue generating
now you can see that see the food and
all will come okay
foreign
you can ask anything like any question
any language question
this code sets up the basic structure
for this game using pi game it include
the functionality for displaying the
snake controlling this movement
detecting collision with the boundaries
and food and managing the score you can
run the code and pay the snake game with
buy game window feel free to customize
see at the end what chat repeat Road
feel free to customize and enhance the
game according your preference okay that
is what I was talking about
you can change
and number of times you can ask n number
of times for the code new new code
okay
there is one why this error is coming
import buy game could not be resolved by
lens
what is the Spy lens okay let me ask to
charge the video only
what is
violence
island is the language server for python
developed by Microsoft which provides
the ones language features including
code completion type checking
static analysis and code navigation
pylons is built on the top of language
server okay
let me give the error itself
copy message
okay
I will write debug error
violence
okay
make sure you have a pi game installed
Pi game is already installed on my
terminal
and run the following command okay let
me open the command prompt
okay then what I have to write
let me copy the code
and paste it here
what is this
okay emergency this is this
if Pi game is not installed you can
re-install by running
already installed I guess
ensure the pylons is using the correct
python to verify that pylon has
converted to use the same path which you
have installed by a game you can check
the python interpreter setting in your
code
editor or ID which make sure it's point
to correct path environment about bios
game is installed
okay
what I will do
I will go to terminal and here I will
write
babe yes star
maybe it will be helpful
okay let me do this
foreign
store new pip
some error of Pi aim I guess okay we'll
run it online no worries
won't work in this I will run it online
okay
see the requirement is already
satisfying this this this
so what we will do we will open
we'll open the plate and we'll create
the new rapple
okay then python
turn and created
okay this is the same like you know one
of the
ID you can say
then
what I will
I will copy the space code
and paste it here
Dot py
okay
on that I will copy the code and I will
run it
okay
separate updating the package and the
project and the buy game
okay it's running the code is running
okay it's installing Pi game
you can let me run now
what happened what's the error
what's the error
okay
okay some hello from PI game Community
this is
T8
okay
okay we'll ask to charge GPT
[Music]
code showing
together
okay
provide
me d
ude
game code using
python
actually
this time from Turtle okay
let's see
because the pie games I don't know Pi
game is installed on my system it's not
working
so we will leave it
okay we'll ask from this some good GI
with some good here
see it is the head everything is the
keyboard bindings from wsd or you can up
down left right the keys
you can use from use the both
okay
continue generating
then the functions the pen the snake
body everything is a snake head is like
everything is here what you want
everything is here
see the code utilize the turtle module
to create the basic game with the snake
that moves collect for the the score is
registered
okay feel free to
let me copy the code
let me copy here only
and run it
see this is the snake
okay this is the food this is the score
or high school okay I will run it
see
you can customize your snake your food
everything see the score
previous time the score was then the
high score now it changes
okay the score is 30 now I'm enjoying
the game
so this is how you can customize your
you know game
okay
let me play the game
okay see this is how you can make any
game or any small small game in two two
three three minutes okay
so uh go to chat GPT and you want the
you know change the color of the snake
or the food anything you can do using
chat GPD
okay
so while this we have to come end of
this video I hope you found this video
informative and interesting if you like
this video give us a thumbs up and share
it with your friends also if you have
any queries about this video this
particular video please feel free to ask
in the comment section below our team
will get back to you as soon as possible
and the course link for the AIML is
provided in the description box below
don't forget to check it out and till
then thank you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you